[Music]
nice to see you sir
[Music]
Wow
and yes I know I know rare in London
what I miss is just a light can I move
in here Patricia because honestly in my
flat what I'm like trying to take a
selfie I don't want to perfect day
though I'll move here like I'll just
leave like you can have a corner a
corner on your kitchen if you ever need
to take pictures of yourself and I'll
make you tea in the morning does that
have a deal
okay for anyone is i lucky it's all good
to me for a friend of it ambassador for
the nori Alex mm-hmm how did you feel
when you know they approached Chile
announced you and obviously you were
kind of the first black ambassador they
have brought in that squad I felt so
privileged because they're a sisterhood
and as you're like they're just thinking
about what's the next thing I'm excited
do you feel the pressure of being a role
model and kind of also cover ground
breaking if you want I go through the
pressure of it I understand it I try not
to think about it too much because if
you start thinking a role model has to
be like this
then you actually end up being just like
you don't end up being yourself and
actually as a role model it's just
better to be you good bad and ugly so
that everybody can see what actually
happens and that is more of a role model
than someone who's thinking I'm a role
model
so you're in my life it's all about
beauty and food the same this is all
ideas ain't and did your makeup so I'm
dying to see your kitchen in your beauty
room let's go let's go see it I love it
this person looks very clean
I mean outside I knew you guys will come
another day you like to cook I cook
every day you cook everything every I
find cooking relaxing hmm and I like to
throw down like normally I mean I don't
throw down everything but it's on a
Sunday I will what's your signature dish
and it's basically rice and chicken okay
alright wise move like a chicken sauce
and some chicken is always rice in my
fridge haven't actually sorted it out or
anything like that I see water tons of
vegetables now I know where that glow
comes from and no but seriously and
literally practice what you preach
yes that is true but this because I love
it I love apples and love carrots I love
Tomatoes so a tree like so up good this
is where the magic happens
[Music]
okay teachers organized this because
we're filming or are you this organ um
honestly I'm currently disorganized I
did this about a couple of weeks ago but
it's like my spring edit for my closet
what are your highlights for spring what
tell me a few bits that you're loving so
it's like the bright colors yeah like
the blues like this I love it pink oh my
gosh loving it
everyone got that pink clothes and pink
jumpers you don't need to buy a new pink
thing so I've got no pink
oh do I only wear black Patricia oh well
I have love
I'm a fashion but what would you wear
underneath it you wouldn't wear that
better nothing
what is that the back of the front this
is the back way oh okay I flip it around
right but you know it want you like that
you're are okay oh my gosh another
Jackie I live for like in every color
like leather
that's really pretty unless and that
some early from yeah looks a bit worn I
love that
Topshop Topshop like three four years
old what are your favorite stores to
shopping Azoff I'm a nasal skull you
know through through River Island and
then like I like to splash a little bit
of designer in terms of handbags and
shoes when I runs do you like um
it's classic so I'm I'm about you know I
like it let's talk about the book that
really matters
yeah Isis beauty yeah let's go do it
[Music]
obviously this is my favorite place in
your house
clearly I talk about my favorite subject
yes yet open your presentation because
to me that that is incredibly
interesting yeah you go okay can we're
going to say NARS sheer thoughts cheer
for the coal-scuttle mat mat making love
you girl
yeah that's my obsession I love it yeah
I know I don't know any same thing it's
okay this is really so good where do you
use that would use it under eyes and
over like little blemishes or I use it
under eyes and I use it around my brows
and then in terms of foundation but it
obviously you've got your trousseau hat
and your infallible malleable yet but
then we've also got one calm Clinique
okay and then what else well I made
tellin it like it oh you are miss
honestly it's
almost like this scare me a little bit
you know I've been like serial enough I
have never seen this in my life oh where
did you get this from I'm so like these
apply it turns to a lip cream wow this
is so cool
yeah ple I had never seen that and yet
what's your kind of philosophy when it
comes to skincare
I love skincare yes the more chemicals
with it I'm not like all for organic
Schneider but I like a bit of acids and
a bit of treatments and a bit of pills
and whatever science is out there making
it better makes me happy because usually
it's quite good or then it's like awful
Patricia I mean you and I are not yeah
yeah I know what are you doing with a
mousse self-tan well
self can works on everybody skin tone I
don't use on my face but for my legs
legs before going on holiday it gives
you a growth we need to talk about here
yes this is how we first met
yes I came to interview you for a series
we were doing on glamour yeah it was a
series on a Purim black hen it was
mainly because I had I wanted to educate
myself so since then you've launched a
line of weaves and you're now gonna
launch wigs as well yeah exactly that
what's the reason you were launching
weaves and wigs was it because you
couldn't find what you wanted out there
hmm
not really I mean there's a lot of ways
and there's a lot of wigs and there's a
lot of companies out there but I think
people sell this story like it's like
Asian and Brazilian and Russian like all
these stories around there and it's just
to make it seem glamorous celebrities do
not talk about the fact that 90% of the
time they're wearing wigs how do you
change your hair blonde green purple
every other day it's not possible what
can we expect from your wigs wig line
that's coming out just things that are a
little bit out of the norm so I wear my
hair quite boring we like this normal
but other girls ought to be able to have
a red wig one day and then a blue
wickham of the day and I want every lady
to the night you know what I don't have
a change of look I might actually just
wear a wig
it's like black gold like oh that feels
so beautiful like amazing I yeah and it
lasted forever so you get them in all
colors
this or textures so when I go away I
wear curly hair extensions and I like
I'm like Rihanna like coming up like a
beach fave what style do you think I
should try oh I would get you a long
middle part wavy blond hair I will make
you so glam JLo JLo all day thank you so
much for having us in your lovely house
thank you for coming I really feel truly
inspired us every time that I mean do I
do thank you for coming to my home today
it was lovely to have a chat with Alex
in the meantime make sure you subscribe
to the glamour channel to see more
content like this
they can also check out my channel as
well
[Music]